jack dorsey confirmed he is mining
bitcoin but not probably the way that
you think about it uh compass mining is
a business uh that's got a service it
hosts supplies and operates
cryptocurrency mining rigs for
individual miners uh who don't want to
worry about purchasing and maintaining
the equipment for themselves um and
somebody said somebody tweeted at kit
andrew said as a bitcoin enthusiast for
years i can't believe it's taken me this
long but i finally pivoted my business
to get into the mining space thanks to
compass mining i couldn't be more
excited and can't wait until february
when the fire the first one up
and jack responded and said i'm trying
mining with compass mining two not
exactly what you would expect from
somebody worth tens of billions of
dollars uh to just
casually state that on twitter but it
seems like what he's probably doing is
he's testing he's trying it out and it's
kind of a plug and play type uh offering
that they have so pretty cool there uh
no secret jack dorsey is into bitcoin a
lot of bitcoin-centric projects um and
uh recently vitalik yesterday gave an
interview uh to bloomberg and vitalik
basically was like nobody trusts
facebook mark zuckerberg is unlikely to
be successful going into the metaverse
and jack dorsey building decentralized
financial products on top of bitcoin is
unlikely to be successful as well he
said it was all pretty much done
yeah
he said skeptical skeptical skeptical
afterwards the politically correct way
of saying it's not it can't go wrong
yeah but also uh when i watch the video
i don't know if i'm uh 100 convinced of
this yet
but if there is a paul krugman like the
internet won't be valuable moment of
people talking about bitcoin and
applications built on top of it it may
be vitalik's comments yesterday uh
vitalik is obviously an incredibly
intelligent guy you can't deny uh the
value that the free market has placed on
ethereum the network but uh pretty
strong comments from him yesterday so
we'll see how that works
when you think of mining mining is
another great way to get asset income if
you buy mining equipment it gives you
income off of it and so when you look at
the historical miner profits we've got a
chart here that will show exactly what
those look like you can see that the
mining profit or the mining profits tend
to uh kind of move in these waves
similar to the bull markets and in the
last 24 hours let's see the mining
reward in the last 24 hours was 41.8
million dollars that is what the miners
globally distributed among all the
miners made 41.8 million dollars pretty
incredible uh and then we also have uh
those miners are all going after the
total circulating bitcoin these are the
bitcoin that have gotten issued into the
circulating supply um and so you can see
why is it uh diagonal up into the right
it's because it's programmatic obviously
every single
block there is a bitcoin reward that
comes along with it and so when you look
at the minor rewards for successfully
completing one block
they have every 210 000 blocks 210 000
blocks go by
dude after 210 000 the reward gets
halved so we start out in 2009 at 50
bitcoin those coins ended up being 50
bitcoin for the first block about 10
minutes next 10 minutes another 50
another 50 another 50 another 50. that
continued for 210 000 blocks or
approximately four years then in 2012 we
went from 50 bitcoin went down to 25
from 25 we went to 12 and a half in 2016
and then obviously last year in may of
2020 we went to 6.25 bitcoin every
single 10 minutes and so it's pretty
incredible to see how a programmatic
system like this works uh obviously
there's only 21 million coins that can
be mined uh but there was only
2.6 million coins that were mined
between the having a 2016 and the having
in 2020. so what that tells you is that
it is becoming harder and harder to get
bitcoin obviously if more and more
people want bitcoin then it is likely
that the supply squeeze is going to
continue to play out and we'll see how
that uh goes
what do we think about jack uh doing
this is this kind of a non uh a
non-story because it's obvious like of
course he and other people are going to
be using uh various types of mining to
to get in the game he's been so involved
in the space i was surprised he wasn't
doing this already but
he could have been he could be already
but i am curious like why he's doing it
like why didn't why is he doing it with
compass and not setting up his own rigs
um well i think it's probably the ease
of use right if i understood it
correctly the business models
essentially they go out and they'll
provide all the infrastructure for you
they'll set it up they'll do everything
and then it essentially just gets sent
to your wallet so you're paying them for
kind of like the uh the operations yeah
well the efficiency of it right like he
doesn't necessarily have to do anything
he just pays them and then they they'll
mine it and they set it up and he pays
for the equipment and everything and
then it gets so you think this is like
an accumulation game for him he's just
trying to get more bitcoin and this is a
way to do it yeah i mean yeah
yeah i think uh i think he probably
wants to mine on his own but it's an
easier way and a cheaper way for him to
do it personally without getting uh
involved in buying the equipment
worrying about the power worrying about
everything like that i also think uh
there's a big lag time right we're only
in august right now and the person who
tweeted said that it might not get set
up till february
because they still have to get the
hardware they have to get their uh
facilities ready you've got to get it
plugged in et cetera and so this isn't
something where when you use some of
these services you just like you know go
in and spin up an ec2 instance on aws
right now you've got to be able to
actually um have they said that uh the
if i remember the article correctly i
think it said that the company has seen
so much demand that they don't have
available units for like if you wanted
to go get one now for another year or 16
months
really yeah
well i mean look it's uh it's expensive
it's a sixty thousand dollar purchase
though should i give a like should i
give out a little free alpha
yeah that's here i mean free alpha all
right and then i'll go next i got a
couple picks
i don't do pics
i just give people sound
things to think about uh
in mining
one of the things you have to be careful
of is
as we go into the tail ends of the bull
market what will happen is there's
obviously a psychological fomo that
occurs so people will say oh bitcoin
went from x price to x times two to x
times three x times four and it's going
up and up and up i won in the game some
people would just go buy bitcoin in the
open market other people will say oh you
know what mining sounds amazing i want
to go and i want to buy some some mining
equipment and so when the price of
bitcoin runs really fast usually what
will happen is the price of the mining
equipment will skyrocket as well so if
you think about let's use easy numbers
let's say that the mining equipment was
a thousand dollars uh before the bull
run as you get into the middle of the
bull run maybe it's 1500 bucks you may
see towards the end of a bull market the
mining equipment could be two thousand
twenty five hundred three thousand
thirty five hundred dollars right uh and
so as you see that spiking one of the
things that people will do is they will
fomo into buying the mining equipment so
let's say that it was at a thousand
dollars pre uh bull market i'm making up
numbers but a thousand dollars now it's
at 3 500 and i go ahead and i buy the
equipment at 3 500 bucks that means that
my initial investment is 3 500
if i then turn around and i pay for uh
electricity and i use it to mine bitcoin
i have to mine
three and a half times as much bitcoin
in order to break even on my investment
than i would have if i bought the
equipment at a thousand bucks right
obviously that's how a initial
investment works here is the problem is
that when you have these blow off tops
if you buy it at the very top the
equipment what occurs is the price draws
down which means that the um the value
of the bitcoin that you're mining ends
up being less or as the price falls into
a bear market and so you actually have
to mine even more bitcoin on a us uh to
get to the same us dollar price point so
if bitcoin's price falls by fifty
percent you have to mine double the
bitcoin so you literally could find
yourself in a situation where you bought
mining equipment at the top of a bull
market at an inflated price so now you
have to mine three and a half times as
much bitcoin if the price stays the same
but then the price falls fifty percent
which means you actually have to mine
seven times as much bitcoin in order to
actually break even on buying the same
exact machine and so it ends up being
really really tough to do that because
you're literally uh basically plugging
in on your way in now that doesn't mean
you shouldn't do mining that doesn't
mean that you uh can't make money if you
were to invest in a bull market or in a
bear market it just simply means you
have to understand the economics and you
have to make sure that you're being
intelligent about what is the cost of
the hardware that i'm buying when is it
going to be plugged in what is the
difficulty
uh likely to be and also
where are we are in a cycle right
because you actually can be better off
waiting to a bear market plugging in
machines on a profitable basis you'll
buy the machines much cheaper because
there isn't as much demand there's not
as much fomo etc so the cost of the
machine is lower and then also you can
uh be able to mine the same amount or
potentially more bitcoin depending on
what happens with hash rate and it
becomes actually more profitable over a
long period of time so you got to be
very very careful there's a ton of ways
to mess it up um but i think that one of
the mistakes i see in mining is when
people end up buying hardware equipment
at the absolute blow off tops paying
that inflated price and then not
realizing the market structure
challenges with having to mine more
bitcoin over a long period of time
because you pay too much and also the
prices fall so they can both work
against you uh hopefully that's not
what's gonna happen to the folks you're
buying right now hey guys thanks so much
for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it